Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my new batman video i've gotten
so many requests from a lot of you messaging me
asking about new batman rumors so i'll try to
explain what's going on because there's a bunch
of stuff flying around the past couple of days
if you're new to the channel be sure to subscribe
to get all the videos there's a bunch of big stuff
happening now because they're filming the batman
movie and they're obviously getting ready to film
the justice league snyder cut reshoots with ben
affleck coming back to film new batman scenes
but just starting with the big stuff first number
five if you didn't see the news a couple of blogs
were reporting rumors about ben affleck's new
contract with dc and warner brothers for batman
what the rumors are claiming are that ben affleck
will do the snyder cut reshoots then do the flash
movie like we all heard now a couple bloggers are
also reporting rumors that he's supposedly going
to do a batman hbo project and more movie cameos
beyond the flash movie so understandably there
have been a lot of changes with dc's plans for
batman in the movies and the tv shows recently
so i'll try to explain what i think is true what
is not true what has actually been confirmed and
what has not been confirmed no joke though there's
actually going to be four different versions of
live action batman next year the robert pattinson
batman and the batman movie ben affleck's batman
in the justice league snyder cut in the flash
movie michael keaton's batman in the flash movie
and then number four is actually ian glenn's
batman on titan season 3 which is also coming
to hbo jorah mormont from game of thrones also
plays a version of batman in the dc multiverse
so number four right now the only thing that has
been confirmed for ben affleck's batman is that
in the next week or two he starts filming the
new scenes with zack snyder for the justice
league snyder cut they haven't fully revealed
what all of his new scenes are going to be
he looks way different now than he did when they
were filming the movie originally back in 2017
he's still jacked it's just that he's way more cut
and leaner now his batman was always swole the way
the christian bale bulked up big time for batman
begins there's a whole funny story the christian
bale told about how christopher nolan got mad at
him for doing that like whoa take it down a notch
i don't want the bodybuilder version of batman
you don't really realize how big ben affleck
was until he starts standing next to some of the
actors though he is freaking huge as his batman
these new justice league snyder cut reshoots and
scenes will only last for like 10 to 14 days tops
probably a little bit less they're supposedly
spending 70 to 80 million dollars maybe even a
little bit more on the snyder cup but that's the
total budget for everything not just the budget
for the reshoots as part of these reshoots they're
bringing back more than half of the justice league
actors like gal gadot's wonder woman cyborg they
even just announced that jared leto was filming
new scenes as his version of the joker i did
a video about that last night too so i'll link
that in the description whatever you thought it
was going to be the snyder cut is going to be
way bigger it is morphed from a large movie
into more of a giant mini series it's going
to be over four hours long they'll be releasing
it in four separate episodes next year on hbo max
so of course i'll do videos for all the episodes
and since they're not doing zack snyder's version
of justice league 2 presumably the ending
of the snyder cut whatever the new ending
winds up being will leave batman ready to pick
up at the beginning of the flash movie as if
not a whole lot of time has gone by even though
chronologically in real life several years will
have gone by by the time we see the flash movie
just because it's been delayed so many times
it's getting really good it's getting
really good now you know anyone who knows
anything about barry allen knows that he's
always late yeah but then when he arrives
he gets stuff done number three though the
reason for that is because they revealed
that ben affleck's batman is going to be building
the flash his new costume in the movie the new
multiverse time travel suit really it's just meant
to be a shiny new redesign of the character they
have a new creative team coming in new director
new writer so they want to do their take on the
flash character and evolve him in a new direction
just based on what zack snyder set up this is what
it's going to look like though notice how it's
designed to look much more organic and highlight
all the speed force energy as it arcs around his
body when he's running hopefully they'll also
fix the way that he runs but he's just gonna pop a
lot more on screen this way so at the beginning of
that movie he'll still have the old justice league
suit and i'll have some scenes with ben affleck's
batman where he gets the new suit also because
we know it's a flashpoint movie and everybody
has seen or read the flashpoint story in batman
is such a big part of that people are wondering
if ben affleck is going to have a similar type
of moment even though they're changing a lot of
the flashpoint story from the comics the way they
explained it is that he will be going back in time
to try and change events to save his mother's
life and mess with the timeline in the process
and traveling the multiverse which is where
you get to michael keaton's batman from the
tim burton movies but the whole reason for them
doing flashpoint and all this multiverse stuff
as the directors and the producers said is so
that they can bring all the dc movies and tv
shows from history in real life into the same
continuity through the shared dc multiverse as
they're calling it when they were talking about it
at the dc fandom panel they played a big montage
with clips from all the old dc movies val kilmer
batman clooney batman christopher reeve superman
everything is all canon now just happening
on different earths so that's how they're
going to explain michael keaton's batman
co-existing with ben affleck's batman because
ben affleck is the batman of the main earth of
the dc eu and that isn't going to change even if
ben affleck never does another dc movie after the
flash movie so this is really key to understanding
the future of ben affleck's batman number two the
rumor though that people have been asking me about
about him doing a batman hbo series is actually
coming from an older rumor that happened before
matt reeves announced that he was doing a
batman hbo spin-off series from his batman
movie with robert pattinson so right now the only
batman related hbo series that they're making
is the matt reeves one it doesn't mean that
they'll never do another batman hbo series
it just means that right now that is it it's
mostly intended to be a gritty crime drama series
prequel to the batman movie just following
the characters from the gotham city police
department during the events of batman year one
so when i say it's a prequel to the batman movie
the batman movie takes place during batman year
two the series takes place during batman year one
the idea is that we're in year two it's the gotham
experiment it's a criminological experiment he's
trying to figure out sort of what he can do that
can finally change this place and in our story
as he's in that mode that's where you meet him and
you see that he is charting what he's doing and
he's seeing that he's not having any of the effect
that he wants to have yet and that is when the
murders start to happen and then the murders begin
to describe sort of the history of gotham in a way
that only reinforces what he knows about gotham
but it opens up a whole new world of corruption
that went much farther but as that story starts
to come out without being an origin tale for him
it ends up being something that touches on his
origins so you start to see that as it starts
to describe this epic history of corruption
in gotham that you start to understand well
where did my family sit in that and that sense
i think all of that is is a way to take a story
that is a detective story a very point of view
story a mystery uh it's got of course you know
action all that kind of stuff but at the end of it
it also is incredibly personal for him even though
it is the story in which he's trying to understand
and unravel this mystery they're filming the movie
right now but they're filming the tv series for
hbo sometime early next year so i think they're
going to try and release it by 2022. it also
recently spotted on the set of the movie big
easter egg a dated custom taxicab sticker saying
that it's 2019 meaning that the batman movie takes
place in present day just further confirming that
it's set on a different earth in the multiverse
than the justice league earth but never say never
there's always the chance that they could choose
to cross over robber pattinson's batman with
other justice league characters like we saw
the superman in wonder woman costumes on the set
of the movie recently so there are versions of
them that have existed on that earth but this is
christopher reeves superman costume so post all
your theories about which earth you think this is
taking place on so even though it sounds confusing
there is a batman hbo show of sorts they haven't
revealed what the title of it's going to be robert
pattinson himself probably won't be featured in
it a lot but it will involve the batman characters
that we'll also be seeing during the batman movie
number one though bringing back around a crisis on
infinite earths how will the new hbo series that
they've announced so far handle crossover with the
dc movies and potential crossover with the
arrowverse shows stuff like titans the green
lantern hbo series which is more space based
we haven't really done a lot of space based dc
movies the way they explain things through that
crisis on infinite earth's ending scene with the
montage of all the different earth sort of
gives you a highlight reel explaining how
they're all treating it now it's all canon it's
all multiverse they're all on different earths
but behind the scenes the way that the producers
and the directors talk about all this the writers
people like matt reeves for instance his batman
hbo series won't start referencing the air over
shows anytime soon they just let the directors and
the producers each do their own thing so if they
want to reference other shows and movies they
can totally do that but they're not required to
so for instance they do this new green lantern hbo
series clearly meant to cross over with the new
green lantern core series we have diggle green
lantern from the arrowverse the green lantern
series doesn't necessarily have to include diggle
but i think they're leaving room in case they
decide to do something like that and just because
the flash movie might be ben affleck's last big
dc movie as batman you know that doesn't mean that
he'll never ever come back to appear as batman we
never thought that michael keaton would come back
as batman but you cut to 20 20 and boom he's back
so hopefully that clears everything up right
now there is no ben affleck batman hbo series
that's going to happen the last movie that is
on his contract right now is the flash movie
so that changes in the next couple of months of
course i'll do a new video but until they make an
official announcement i would just treat a lot of
those rumors with grains of salt many many grains
of salt the next big thing that's happening though
is the mandalorian season 2 episodes are starting
next week i'll be doing videos for all the
episodes so make sure you've enabled alerts for my
channel so you don't miss anything but leave all
your video requests in the comments below for any
kind of video while you wait for everything click
here to re-watch all the easter eggs and footage
from the batman movie set clips this past week
and click here to re-watch the batman trailer a
billion more times thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!